thierry solère députés les républicains
de boulogne-billancourt dans les
hauts-de-seine est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir je rappelle que vous êtes
également chargé de l'organisation de la
primaire de votre parti et du centre ce
sera en 2016
merci donc d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
comme chaque semaine trois parties et
trois grandes questions premièrement
françois hollande est il à la hauteur
des enjeux se révèle-t-il comme chef de
l'état 2 comme chef de guerre mondiale
également contre le groupe état
islamiste est actuellement on le sait à
washington et il est toute la semaine
vous le savez de par le monde pour
rencontrer ses homologues des pays
siégeant en permanence au conseil de
sécurité de l'onu mme deuxième question
qui a failli puisque vous réclamer un
audit sur les services de sécurité et de
renseignement du pays mais les
défaillances et les faiblesses face à la
radicalisation ne concerne pas que les
services mais aussi des pans de la
société
eh bien vous répondrai tout à l'heure à
perrine tarneaud de public sénat enfin
troisième question de l'émission thierry
solère pourquoi votre parti apparemment
votre parti des républicains semblent à
la peine à moins de deux semaines
maintenant du premier tour des élections
régionales et la cena des spiel jacques
de la fp qui vous le demandera
françois hollande donc se révèle t-il
comme chef de guerre selon vous il
annonce une série de mesures
sécuritaires d'ailleurs plébiscité par
l'opinion il multiplie les rencontres
avec ses plus grands homologues de la
planète pour une action efficace contre
le groupe etat islamique le chef de
l'état est il selon vous à la hauteur
des enjeux ont d'abord ces attentats ont
frappé tout le monde est bien sûr quand
il ya quelque chose de si graves qui se
passe en france on se tourner vers les
pouvoirs publics et le président de la
république au congrès a eu les mots
justes pour dénoncer ce qui se passait
et d'un sentiment de prendre la mesure
du problème
après donc il est allé auteurs alors
après mon rôle à moi et être député
d'opposition s'est pas de vous sortir
des petites phrases pour vous dire des
facilités
fifa moi c'est que au delà des
prochaines échéances régionales dans un
mois enfin dans quinze jours maintenant
les élections présidentielles dans
longtemps que cela
le gouvernement français parce que je
suis parlementaire je vote les lois jeu
contrôler l'action du gouvernement
prenne les bonnes mesures d'urgence bien
sûr matière de sécurité publique
et puis également à court terme et à
moyen terme pour que la situation en
france s'améliore sur le front la
sécurité publique
là et là il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
d'accord est ce que vous craignez
puisqu'il ya une question d'actualité
qui se pose que le sukhoï russe qui a
été abattu par la turquie et la
frontière avec la syrie tout à leur
remettant en question justement
l'ambition française d'une vaste
coalition contre contre le groupe etat
islamique
bon alors d'abord sur ce sujet
international depuis des mois qu'est ce
que nous réclamons je pense notamment à
bono le maire hockey dont je suis proche
que vous actuellement soutien n'attendez
pas encore officiellement candidat
brillante en 2010 et ont tout cela mais
qu'est ce que nous réclamons nous
réclamons à françois hollande depuis des
mois qu'il prenne l'initiative d'une
coalition internationale
en niveau de l'onu des nations unies
pour qu'il y ait une intervention
unanime au sol en syrie parce qu'on ne
sortira pas de la situation de l'état
islamique sur le territoire syrienne sur
le territoire irakien
sans une seule coalition avec nationale
et donc pour cela ou illusion deux
choses il ne faut pas faire du départ de
bachar el-assad à préalable à tout et
deuxièmement il faut prendre reprendre
langue avec les russes parce que
l'annulation d'une grande nation marc
morand ses blessures vous pouvez
l'écrire aussi que françois girard
depuis des mois on cela depuis des mois
nous savions il y avait eu beaucoup
d'attentats en france il ya eu les
attentats du mois de janvier il ya eu
d'autres attentats certains ont été
déjoués certains on a pu bénéficier de
chance je parlais de l'attentât du
thalys le premier ministre nous a dit à
de multiples reprises que nous savions
tous c'est que la france était
confrontée à des attaques terroristes
je suis pas très heureux de constater
tous ces mois perdus pour que le
président de la république change enfin
complètement de pied sur un plan
diplomatique et fasse maintenant de sa
priorité
l'élimination de l'état islamique et pas
une autre la diplomatie c'est de
chercher ses intérêts stratégiques
l'intérêt stratégique de la france nous
a fallu attendre selon vous les
attentats du 13 novembre
faut pas couper aujourd'hui mais c'est
facile dit aujourd'hui oui moi
j'entendais encore monsieur le drian il
ya quelques semaines de nous expliquer
que l'intervention au sol n'était
réclamé par aucun n'est pas qu'elle
n'était pas la solution et qu'il ne
fallait pas retravailler avec les russes
tant que l'affairé craignait n'était pas
réglée et les militaires les unitaires
ont toujours dit qu'ils me faire
français qui fait lui aussi une
intervention au sol la quête de savoir
de la part du corps d'amy compagne avant
sont aujourd'hui donc le président de la
république après cet attentat qui a
coûté la vie à 130 de nos compatriotes
change d'avis et veut mobiliser une
grande coalition je m'en réjouis je me
félicite qu'il soit aujourd'hui aux
états unis et qu'il rencontre l'ensemble
des grands leaders du européens et
occidentaux notamment à l'occasion de la
coop 21 pour que si elle cette grande
coalition mais j'ai vu la première
résolution des nations unies la semaine
dernière elle ne règle pas encore toutes
les ambiguïtés on voit bien encore de
9,29 vert mais elle n'est pas sous le
bon chapitre en particulier il n'y a pas
une large coalition tous ensemble pour
aller sur le territoire syrien éradiquer
l'état islamique et vous me parlez la
question que vous me posez c'est par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
absolument avec les russes
la première question j'ai envie de poser
au président la république c est ce que
les russes sont nos alliés j'ai compris
que la marine russe et paul est notre
porte avions charles de gaulle dans la
zone
ben écoute et aujourd'hui on a une
question au parlement à l'assemblée
nationale d'un député à l'est
républicain qui a interpellé le premier
ministre sur les sanctions à l'endroit
de la russie on peut pas être allié avec
la considérer que les coûts élevés
bien sûr d'accord pour ne pas aller
là-bas question portait peut-être plus
sur la turquie est ce qu'il faut
l'incriminé est ce que la turquie
cherche en abattant cet avion russe
aujourd'hui il ya quelques heures le
lien à torpiller les efforts de paris
notamment pour monter cette grande
alliance entre les occidentaux et la
russie
moi je pense que nous avons le président
landais l'ensemble des dents pays on a
demandé des comptes très précis à la
turquie sur ses alliés la turquie est
censé être notre allié dans cette
affaire tout le monde est liée contre le
terrorisme aujourd'hui et à la prise de
conscience générale et tenter ce que
c'est le cas de l'action est vraiment
bon bah c'est la question précise et par
rapide
on doit poser au bout
man turc en lui demandant de clarifier
tout cela risque de l'alaska pardon
signal de voir l'armée turque en train
d'abattre un avion puisque la turquie
nous nous met un coup de poignard dans
le dos comme le pour reprendre
l'expression de vladimir poutine avait
raison mais en tout cas ce départ un
comportement qui est très rassurant
il ya beaucoup de suspicion à l'endroit
de beaucoup pays moi je demande ce que
la france demande à tous les pays à ces
pays du golfe à ces monarchies du golfe
à la turquie de clarifier d'urgence
leurs positions est ce que oui ou non
ils sont à nos côtés pour lutter contre
des thaïs l'année qui est une menace
directe pour nos pays direct pour la
france la france est l'un des principaux
pays visés par les timings nous l'avons
encore revu le 13 novembre dernier et
cette urgence diplomatique elle est
d'importance je suis persuadé que le
président la république le fera alors
clarifier est ce que nous devons
également nous clarifier nos relations
par exemple avec l'arabie saoudite et le
qatar flambeau je pense que s'il y a des
suspicions de comportement de ces
monarchies du golfe à l'endroit de ces
organisations terroristes qu'elles
doivent être levés d'urgence et que la
priorité numéro 1 n'est pas de vendre
des avions à ces pays la presse de
l'otan on le fait beaucoup la priorité
numéro un et leur demander une
clarification de leur position et si
leur position continue a durablement ne
pas être claires par rapport à nous en
jeu des intérêts stratégiques
à nous d'en tirer toutes les
conséquences alors on va écouter manuel
valls tout à l'heure lors des questions
d'actualité il a précisé justement ce
que françois hollande cherche à obtenir
lors de son marathon diplomatique cette
semaine nous avons un adversaire cedej
et chaque pays et notamment les pays de
la région doit venir tous et tous ceux
qui sont concernés par ce conflit que
leurs adversaires cédait ch et nous ne
doutez pas un seul instant que le
président de la république à cette
volonté faire en sorte que demain
grâce à cette coalition grâce à cette
action grâce à la clarification des
positions de chacun cet ennemi
d'hachette organisation terroriste sera
annulée voilà donc la recherche d'une
coalition concernant une intervention au
sol que vous réclamez thierry solère
boulevard avec la minute de la part de
qu'elle paye et de pays arabes de la
région
je pense qu'il faut une seule coalition
internationale il faut donc avoir réglé
ce problème avec la russie et arrêter de
faire du départ de bachar el-assad le
préalable à tout esprit bachar el-assad
et l'avenir de la syrie bien sûr que non
il faut en parallèle
et un travail politique pour préparer
l'après en ciel mais à partir de là il
faut une coalition et tous les experts
militaires internationaux 20010 on
arrivera pas on n'éradiquera pas l'état
islamique en syrie et en irak uniquement
par des bombardements et paris maintient
une intensification de ces bombardements
donc après est-ce que c'est des soldats
français qui doivent être en première
ligne le réclame non répond globalement
nous mais pas entendu personne avec les
messages depuis des mois bruno le maire
réclame que la france prenne
l'initiative diplomatique pour
l'intervention au sol d'une coalition
internationale les pays du golfe avec la
turquie avec la russie a coûté beaucoup
de temps a été perdu
aujourd'hui la france l'armée française
elle est très très présente sur la bande
sahélienne
je vois bien que ce n'est pas une
solution d'enlever nos soldats là-bas
parce que sinon le terrorisme rose
prospérera à nouveau et une coalition
c'est à vous êtes amant nous la france
qui y en a des troupes à sable justement
il ya quelques minutes barack obama et
françois hollande ont annoncé à
washington qu'il soutenait que la france
et les états unis lé soutenir toute
intervention au sol qui devrait se
décider
c'est une très bonne nouvelle mais je
crains parce que je le constate depuis
des mois que la situation des états unis
des rues c'est souvent une situation qui
est très bloquée et ç'a toujours été la
tradition de la france et un pays non
alignés et qui visait à rapprocher des
positions moins aujourd'hui j'espère je
souhaite que françois hollande à
l'occasion de ses déplacements et à
l'accasion encore une fois de la cap 21
qui au delà de l'environnement qui est
un sujet très important à bien sûr se
transformer en grand ce maire en lutte
anti terroriste puisse participer à
rapprocher ses positions tout le monde
comprend bien que si les états unis et
la russie et l'ensemble des pays du
golfe et la turquie et y ait une grande
puissance européenne ne sont pas tous en
même sens mobilisez pourrait radicaliser
l'état islamique on n'y arrivera pas
alors voilà ce que nous réclamons depuis
un gars bien vite compte que doit plus
considérés pour l'instant bachar el
assad comme comme le diable si j'entends
bien ce que vous dites je n'ai pas une
porte un jugement positif sur bachar
quelques ratés et en moins nous allons
implanter un moment opposition à laurent
fabius qui n'est pas la contacter le
président de la république l'a aux états
unis est la réponse qui nous a été
opposé à chaque fois c'est que la
priorité de la france c'était d'obtenir
le départ de bachar el-assad
bah oui que quand on tient ses positions
pendant des mois et des mois qu'est ce
qui se passe n'a pas grand-chose
d'accord mais aujourd'hui par exemple
qui viseront les
les militaires français vont se
concerter avec avec les russes cela veut
dire que de facto on va aussi se
concerter militairement avec avec les
militaires de bachar el-assad est de
facto un oui j'ai vu comme vous que
quand le président de la république a
décidé l'envoi du porte-avions le
charles-de-gaulle sur zone
c'est la marine russe qui a épaulé ce
déplacement aujourd'hui logistique
donc nous travaillons avec eux c'est
pour ça qu'il est dommage depuis
maintenant plus d'un an d'avoir connu
cette affaire de du refus de la vente
des deux frégates qui a participé
considérablement à dégrader nos
relations diplomatiques avec la russie
et qu'il est dommage que la france n'est
pas jouer le rôle qui historiquement
encore une fois est le sien c'est-à-dire
de rapprocher les positions
la france n'a jamais été un pays ali
deuxièmement l'iran nous avions réclamé
depuis longtemps également que la
situation évolue sinon leur land aurait
pu dès le lendemain de son élection
travailler à ce sujet je trouve que la
sphère iranienne a évolué à cause du
clip de l'accord nucléaire
il rentre une grande puissance il faut
aujourd'hui très clairement que nous
soyons engagés guéri quel que soit
l'accord je vous pose la question est ce
que françois hollande est à la hauteur
des objets aujourd'hui vous répondez oui
mais il ya tout ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers ont répondu oui je vous ai
répondu qu' il avait la dignité de au
principal locaux loués prendre les
grandes décisions et d'aujourd'hui
d'ouvrir les yeux sur la nécessité de
changer d'alliance stratégique et de
changer de positionnement pour répondre
si vous méprenez pas oui vous me
répondez non il n'est pas la hauteur des
enjeux
ben clair je veux pas rajouter cette
petite phrase c'était la question alors
répondre à la question est ce qu'il est
à hauteur à la hauteur ou non des hors
jeu aujourd'hui est ce que vous voyez
effectivement comme un chef de guerre
mondiale crédible oui ou non non je dors
je ne vous dirai pas ça aussi alors je
suis ici je vous réponds que je dis
depuis dix mois il n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait faire aujourd'hui il change
complètement de ce que vous dites là on
peut dire d'autres responsables aussi de
votre parti des républicains à la gpe
aussi il a évolué sur la russie sur
bachar et je ne reproche jamais à des
gens à d'évoluer et si la france c'est
pas des évolutions
c'est un salto arrière qui a été fait
sur beaucoup de sujets et en matière de
politique intérieure et en matière de
politique extérieure en matière de dit
massy voilà aujourd'hui on change la
france je m'en réjouis c'est ce que je
réclame être plus longues heures là à z
voilà je voudrais qu'on ne change
vraiment et qu'on en tire toutes les
conséquences
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on les
a pas encore tous deux tirés pardon qui
peut comprendre qu'on soit alliée avec
la russie sur place dans la coalition
entre l'état islamique et que par
ailleurs la france soit à la pointe de
sanctions économiques à travers l'union
européenne va colère des autres clubs et
2e en matière de politique intérieure on
va sûrement paris dans le détail
absolument totale de coude annonces qui
ont été faites qui font un changement
radical par rapport à ce qui a été fait
avant les attentats
et c'est souvent des propositions de loi
qui ont été apportés par des députés
les républicains depuis maintenant un an
également réclamée par le pr nisand et à
qui nous avons et à qui le gouvernement
a opéré un refus systématique non
alors maintenant c'est très bien on va
passer l'émission à dire ce qui est ce
qui est fait aujourd'hui aurait dû être
fait plus tôt parce qu'il va falloir
tenir compte de la nouvelle situation de
la nouvelle donne vous êtes d'accord
enfin la nouvelle donne n'est pas si
nouvelle je vous rappelle qu on n attend
pas considérable d'années que la france
a connu beaucoup d'attentats terroristes
et que le premier ministre à de
nombreuses reprises nous a dit que la
france était confrontée à la menace
terroriste de premier amplitude voilà je
m'en fous je trouve particulièrement un
dommage d'annoncer des mesures au
lendemain des attentats qui auraient pu
l'être havre accord alors la semaine
diplomatique avait commencé avec la
rencontre à l'elysée avec david cameron
en l'écoutant je soutiens fermement
l'action que le président olemps dans
l'entreprise pour frapper l'état
islamique en syrie j'ai la ferme
conviction que la grande bretage date en
faire de même
voilà donc ils cherchent donc le soutien
de son parlement à londres pourrait
effectivement avoir une action plus
vigoureuse également auprès de ses
alliés
david cameron est ce que vous vous
attendez une
véritable solidarité aujourd'hui des
pays européens
forcément en terme d'engagement
militaire mais en terme de soutien
financier parce qu'aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que la france est bien seul
c'est vrai moi je suis persuadé que la
menace que constitue ce terrorisme de
l'islam radical
l'état islamique et toutes les branches
d'al qaïda en afrique ne vise pas que la
france
elle vise l'ensemble des grands pays
européens et les etats-unis et la france
est seule au front nom est la seule la
france par rapport à noter un tous les
fronts en afrique seuls à assumer
notamment en afrique
l'ensemble des missions et je pense je
souhaite j'espère que ce qui vient de se
passer d'une prise de conscience
générale avec le président de la
république pour le coup et je salue ce
travail là aujourd'hui participe de
faire ouvrir les yeux à ses homologues
européens notamment sur la nécessité
d'avoir une réaction européenne qui soit
à la hauteur de l'événement vous savez
beaucoup il ya parfois de la défiance
par rapport à l'europe où aller comment
ne peut-il pour comment ils pourraient
favoriser ce que je veux dire que quand
je pourrai être autrement quand on voit
sur les sujets financiers la crise
grecque de voir l'europe ne réagir que
au pied du mur quand on voit la crise
des migrants arrivés et quand on voit
l'europe ne commencer à réagir qu'au
pied du mur et que alors que beaucoup de
pays européens les états unis dès le 11
septembre 2001 encore récemment à boston
avec cet attentat à l'occasion du
marathon d'autres pays européens nous la
france à deux reprises majeur dans cette
année 2015 elle touchée par le
terrorisme de voir que la réponse est si
lente à arriver donc voilà donc on a
raison aujourd'hui par exemple françois
hollande a raison de dire le pacte de
stabilité oui ça attendra d'abord le
pacte de sécurité
c'est aussi une réponse aux tu as et une
photo terrible de sa part je suis
persuadé que la france n'arrivera pas
durablement à assumer une mission
régalienne nécessaire qui aujourd'hui
n'est pas suffisamment mise en oeuvre on
ne retrouvera pas une souveraineté
budgétaire et on n'a pas de souveraineté
budgétaire quand on laisse filer les
déficits
deuxièmement je pense que le réaction
qui nous sont annoncés sur un plan
intérieur ne sont pas du tout à la
hauteur de ce qu'il fallait à l'envers
d'avant sur un plan financier
600 millions de plus dans le budget de
l'état c'était pas du tout à la hauteur
priorité nationale je vous met ça en
réverbération de deux trois autres
chiffres
vous savez on a payé un milliard d'euros
à une entreprise ecomouv parce qu'on a
changé d'avis sur l'installation de
tentes hic pour la pour la taxe poids
lourds oui un milliard en moins dans les
caisses de l'état
si la priorité nationale c'est la
sécurité de nos compatriotes 600
millions pour l'année 2016 me paraissent
pas être tout à fait à la hauteur
donc je pense que c'est une mauvaise
manière il faut impérativement retrouver
une souveraineté budgétaire diminuer la
voilure là où il ya trop d'état parce
que l'état souvent est une contrainte
pour beaucoup en arriver là le paquet
mais on peut y arriver là avec les
forces sécuritaires mais on peut y
arriver si on prend des vraies décisions
et de priorités budgétaires et
deuxièmement je vous en dirai un mot
tout à leur devoir de faire un grand
tour d'horizon de toutes nos
défaillances
alors on en parle et on va en parler je
signale juste avant de passer la
deuxième avant de passer à la deuxième
partie qui a eu 11 morts
tout à l'heure vous l'avez entendu dans
l'explosion d'un bus de la sécurité
présidentielle en tunisie 14 mort 2e
partie de preuves par 3 donc thierry
solère avec perrine tarneaud qui arrive
pour vous poser cette question qui a
failli puisque vous réclamer un audit
sur les services de sécurité et de
renseignement vous-même d'ailleurs vous
apporter un témoignage assez éclairant
est édifiant sur ce qui se passe dans
certaines prisons par exemple à nanterre
c'était sous l'oeil des caméras de zone
interdite de ses directeurs c'est moi ou
ça sentait le
savait il fume fume de la drogue qui s'y
dans les couloirs on va d'abord et
surtout
pas là le gris fumé et vous avez des
gens qui dérangent téléphones portables
ou des téléphones des volets de dechy
toutes sortes de choses période de
ramadan qui génère beaucoup de manques
de produits alimentaires mais on n'est
pas à l'abri qu'à un moment donné on
fait tâche et l'on peut aussi avoir des
l'émission est survenu série qui vous
pouvez savoir à voir des téléphones
portables gestion on retrouve bien
entendu
on les donne un ami
messi
c'est un peu pas trop ces analyses et
chrono il faut il faudrait qu'on est
quasiment à surveiller en permanence
avec bonsoir père et arnaud on vient de
voir effectivement cet extrait de ce
reportage qui a été diffusé dimanche
pascal pas tous des mesures toutes
simples à prendre pour remédier à ces
problèmes en prison bien sûr oui nous
les députés on est des contrôleurs de
lieux de privation de liberté on peut
aller en prison quand on veut moi j'y
vais régulièrement au seul ou avec des
collègues
j'y suis retournée avec david douillet
la semaine dernière qu'est-ce que j'ai
eue pour aller très simple très vite
trois choses à des téléphones portables
par tous en prison
le directeur m'a avoué on avait trouvé
des téléphones portables dans la cellule
de détenus qui revenait de syrie quand
on a un téléphone portable s'est
connecté à internet ça veut dire que des
gens qui reviennent dossier et qui sont
suivis pour des actes de terrorisme
ils ont un téléphone portable ils sont
contrés tech listre avec l'extérieur
voir avec l'étranger est ce qu'ils sont
c'est un homme installé quelque chose la
première chose à faire c'est d'installer
des brouilleurs alors là vous répondre
ça coûte cher
oui bien sûr il faut évaluer combien ça
coûte à mon avis ça doit coûter à un peu
près une centaine de millions d'euros ou
81 millions d'euros quand même assez de
l'argent mais est-ce que gouverner c'est
pas trouver des solutions et fils et des
priorités
est ce que dans le budget de l'état qui
est absolument considérable
je vous parle même pas du budget des
collectivités locales et tout ce qui va
avec c'est à la hauteur de ne pas
répondre à cette nécessité impérieuse
d'empêcher des détenus qui sont
dangereux de pouvoir communiquer par
internet et par téléphone un résident
ailleurs c'est une priorité dont vous
allez faire de ces constatations vous
allez on va saisir le gouvernement on va
saisir le gouvernement pour tout vous
dire dès demain à l'assemblée nationale
à la question des questions au
gouvernement comme ça madame taubira le
saura david douillet saisira madame
taubira de me demandes très précises qui
auront des impacts budgétaires
est-ce qu'on ait la capacité d'installer
des brouillards dans les prisons
françaises dans un délai rapide
oui ou non oui on l'est on les
techniquement oui on l'est à condition
qu'on ait des marges de manoeuvre et je
reviens à la question posée
on ne fera pas ça on laissant glisser
les déficits il faut donc et c'est ça ou
vernet si on a besoin de personne à la
tête de l'état on doit faire des
arbitrages et moi je pense que il est le
temps il est venu le temps d'arrêter
d'avoir un état en france qui est
partout et parce qu'il s'occupe de tout
fait globalement tout mal
il faut que l'état s'occupe massivement
de ses missions régaliennes la justice
la série est passée aussi qu'elle ait
pas tellement d'années le sens là moi
j'ai 44 ans j'ai acquis 36 mois je ne
suis pas là pour regarder ce qu'elle
vient faire et françois mitterrand
jacques chirac nicolas sarkozy nicolas
sarkozy bien sûr y'a parce que je suis
regardé
quel est l'état de la situation de notre
pays le niveau de la fiscalité de mon
pays
est ce qu'on demande comme effort à tous
les contribuables qui est légitime et
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on fait de leur
argent
et moi je vous dis personne n'a pas
d'états d'âme sur la sécurité publique
dans la rue s'il ne le fait pas bien
personne ne le fera à sa place personne
n'a parlé de tout ce qui est des prisons
personne à part l'état ne s'occupe de la
défense nationale et donc il est venu le
temps d'avoir le courage parce que c'est
ça dont il s'agit
le courage politique de prendre des
décisions pour recentrer les passions
ses missions régaliennes et peut-être le
courage politique aussi de recruter les
baisses d'effectifs en matière de
sécurité du temps de nicolas sarkozy
oui à benoît il ya débat sur le sujet
j'ai encore vu un bonbon l'autre jour
j'ai chiffres il ya pas tellement de
débat ça s'il avait un débat sur les
chiffres et encore moins de policiers
depuis cette année qu'il n'y en avait en
2012 et moi je les ai toujours dit je
pense que la rgpp ce n'est pas
obligatoirement sur les sujets régaliens
qui allait le faire vous savez on peut
se renvoyer gauche et droite
moi je vous dis pas que la droite a tout
bien fait depuis trente ans beaucoup
d'écueils qu'est ce qui m'importe moi
moi je viens du privé je suis
parlementaire g et élise une élue par
les habitants de boulogne c'est
d'apporter des solutions concrètes à ce
qu'attendent n'en restons justement aux
solutions concrètes que vous proposez
d'abord à partir du constat sur
certaines failles tu pour ne pas dire
faillite dans le deuxième groupe un
deuxième exemple tu as peut-être
justement pour rester en prison sur
cette visite que vous avez effectué avec
david douillet ce qui était marqué on
sait que le directeur de prison ne s'est
pas finalement qui est fiché s dans son
établissement ça je vais expliquer les
choses très simplement si vous avez rita
qui fait un braquage un vol à main armée
il est arrêté par la police est très
bien on a une police de qualité il va le
placer en détention provisoire et sarah
renvoyé devant la justice dans mx mois
pour être jugé pour ce braquage à marne
et s'il se trouve que cette même
personne parallèlement été suivie par la
direction centrale du renseignement
intérieur pour des actes liés à des
réseaux terroristes et qu'il a une fiche
est ce de la plus grande gravité sur ces
sujets là bas quand ils arrivent en
détention le direct la maison d'arrêt ne
le sait pas donc qu'est ce qu'il en fait
ils le placent dans une cellule avec
d'autres détenus eh bien non c'est comme
ça quoi radicalise les autres le
prosélytisme a lieu à cette occasion là
comment c'est possible
en france aujourd'hui que nos différents
services ne communique pas les
informations les uns avec les autres
tout prend un troisième exemple en
dehors de la prison exactement sur le
même sujet on a tous vu un des
terroristes qui s'est fait exploser dans
le quartier du bataclan on connaît son
passé judiciaire octobre 2012
il est placé sous contrôle judiciaire
suivie par la direction du renseignement
intérieur la justice lui confisque
passeports et cartes d'identité avec une
assignation à résidence
il part en syrie très vite comment ils
pas renchérit avec un passeport
comment il a le passeport la justice lui
a retiré c est ce qu il a fait il est
allé au commissariat du coin et il
aurait déposé un acte ii de verre ou de
vol de document d'identité et le
ministère de l'intérieur lui à rémy un
nouveau titre écoutez moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse une surenchère législative
ne comptez pas sur moi pour vous
demander cinquante milliards de mesures
toujours plus sécuritaire pour jouer au
plus sécuritaire je crois que les gens
ils sont en droit d'attendre pour mettre
le paquet sur les sujets régaliens et
c'est pour ça que j'ai réclamé qu'on
fasse un audit général de tourner notre
héros nous y invitait alors écoutez
d'abord ce que dit le syndicaliste jean
françois forget c'est le président du
syndicat pénitentiaire ufap à propos
justement de la radicalisation dans les
prisons il ya une trentaine de détenus
qui apprennent aujourd'hui sont
effectivement à l'écart des autres et qu
ils sont déjà eu entre eux ce qu'il
faudrait éviter pour et les séparait
déjà entre eux mais sur un certain
nombre de moments de la journée je pense
aux certaines activités et les parloirs
où l'infirmerie
ils se retrouvent
avec d'autres co détenus ils peuvent
échanger à travers les cours de
promenade à travers les fenêtres
il n'y a aucune étanchéité on n'est pas
dans un système il faut pour demain si
on veut avancer de façon claire avoir
des établissements à part entière où on
gère ces détenus à part des autres ça
c'est sûr mais aussi à part entre eux de
façon à ce qu'on puisse avoir un travail
efficace tel qu'on le réclame depuis 20
ans oui nous voyons des gens se
radicaliser dans nos prisons dire que
les prisons est le seul endroit où
radicalise non dire que c'est un endroit
privilégié de la résignation oui voilà
pour ce témoignage recueilli par
géraldine beys walo et jordan klein
alors la radicalisation en prison c'est
quoi la solution selon vous est ce que
c'est d'avoir des établissements qui
accueillent uniquement des radicaliser
d'abord il faut savoir qui est
radicalisée ou pas et comment se passe
cette radicalisation je vous dis hein
déjà les gens qui sont ultra radicaliser
parce qu'ils sont engagés dans des
logiques terroristes en contact avec la
syrie ou qui en reviennent
cela me semble-t-il il faut pas les
mettre en contact avec les autres
j'ai tu suis me suis rendu à fresnes
j'ai vu l'expérimentation qui prenait
par le gouvernement qui a demandé au
gouvernement là bas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concrètement ça veut dire en
gros on les met à l'isolément
ils sont tous dans la série d'individus
alors c'est sûr qu'ils voient plus grand
monde c'est plutôt bien
est-ce qu'ils vont être des radicaliser
ce qu'il faut généraliser ces
l'annoncent café manuel valls moi je
veux pas vous donner une réponse de
facilité je pense que c'est très
compliqué j'ai étudié à l'étranger ce
que faisaient d'autres pays en matière
de déradicalisation c'est très difficile
de voir des résultats de bonne solution
l'allemagne est pas certain que ça soit
par des petites phrases qu'on arrivera à
trouver des solutions aisées sur le
sujet en tout cas une nécessité absolue
c'est de protéger la société des gens à
l'intérieur et qui sont dans cette
logique aujourd'hui
et deuxièmement quand ils arrivent en
prison ceux qui sont dans une logique de
radicalisation absolue qu'ils ne
puissent pas contaminer les autres
et voyez ça serait bien que le ministère
l'intérieur puisse communiquer aux
directeurs de maison d'arrêt de notre
pays
cette décision je ne vois pas au nom de
quel principe ce n'est pas possible
le cfcm a c'est à dire le conseil
français du culte musulman va mettre en
place une habilitation 10 imams à ce que
ça ça va dans le bon sens
est-ce qu'on pourrait s'appuyer par
exemple sur eux concernant justement la
déradicalisation c'est un sujet très
qui n'est pas nouveau nicolas sarkozy
pour le coup à l'époque quand il était
président de la république avait essayé
de travailler sur ce sujet avec la
création du conseil français du culte
musulman
moi je notre système c'est la laïcité
c'est la république en république les
religions se soumettent à la république
toutes les religions et pas l inverse
c'est le cas de la religion catholique
ça s'est passé rappelez-vous notre
histoire pas facilement
ça a duré très longtemps et ça a été
très compliqué c'est le cas avec la
religion juive
voilà les gens juive il est clairement
indiqué qu on se soumet aux lois de
l'état
indépendamment ce qui a marqué dans la
torah et vous avez la prière à la
république française qui est lui dans
les synagogues mais régulièrement mais
il faut que l'islam de france se
structure que l'escale en france se
structure et que soit envoyé là y avait
bien sûr mais il fallait continuer il
fallait continuer à travailler sur ces
sujets là deuxièmement moi je pense
qu'il faut et maintenant dans les actes
et pas dans les mots expulsés de france
tous les imams salafistes étrangers qui
profère des propos qui ne sont pas
compatibles avec la république
on a tous vu surtout à une chaîne de
télévision des exemples très précis et
il n'ira beaucoup dans beaucoup
d'endroits et ce ne sont pas
malheureusement des cas isolés
donc c'est une urgence mes côtés pour
faire cela est ce qu'il ya un problème
juridique
ci-après mais j'aurais dit qu'on initie
au parlement à bahreïn ont leurs règles
et puis ensuite mettons les moyens pour
avoir de l'efficacité et faisons le
savez dans toute structure au monde
quand vous avez un accident quand il ya
le paris rio qui fait naufrage en plein
océan atlantique et vous avez plein de
morts vous allez au lendemain on appelle
un audit complet des process de sécurité
à tous les étages
parce que c'est pas possible que ça
recommence la france elle a été frappée
massivement par les terroristes
c'était pas la première fois on pouvait
pas dire qu'on ne s'y attendait pas et
130 morts moi je suis parlementaire j'ai
deux fonctions madame à la roja de
fonctions clés noires
je vote les lois et je contrôle l'action
du gouvernement et moi je demande au
gouvernement un manuel valls d'instaurer
très rapidement comme ça se passerait
dans toute structure monde
un audit très précis non partisan avec
des députés de différentes formations
très nombreux cépages unis siens c'est
un audit précis qu'on balaye tous les
process comment c'est possible le cas du
passeport coûte et c'est uniquement dans
les services administratifs ou alors
également dans les mains
et on ferme les yeux parfois sur
certains confrères allemands un déjà une
entreprise aussi par déjà un dans la
cire de l'état on balaye toutes les
grandes procédure et qu'on fasse
remonter là où des difficultés et qu'on
les règle pour demain n'existe plus
franchement c'est pas très compliqué ça
se passe comme ça partout - choses et
l'audit avant d'être parlementaire
croyez-moi quand vous avez une
entreprise très compliqué qui a beaucoup
de problèmes
on nous dit on voit là où il ya des
problèmes on les vagues que les
commissions parlementaires c'est que les
gens les gens qui témoignent devant vous
prêtent serment donc ça vous permet si
vous voulez d'encadrer les choses c'est
tout sera bien peu probable mais moi je
ne suis pas juge je vois bien un usage
de la commission enquête parlementaire
je suis pas là pour que son craie
lannutti judiciaire je suis là pour
concret à l'audience technique de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
qu'on avait sur place comme on l'a fait
avec david douillet en prison quand vous
allez en prison et on n'est pas le seul
à le faire moi je suis allé plus de dix
fois non et maison d'arrêt où dans des
prisons ben vous voyez très bien les
dysfonctionnements et bien que dès qu'on
fasse ça plusieurs gauche droite réunies
et puis qu'on liste une quinzaine de
choses à faire en urgence
et puis qu'on les fasse et que ça soit
pas reporté je ne sais pas quelle loi de
programmation ou à des gouvernements
prennent des mesures qu'ils ont
l'habitude de faire cela c'est pas
quelque chose qui nous vaut pour eux
depuis quelques jours donc ça va pas les
déranger
sur la déchéance de nationalité je vous
propose d'écouter la proposition d'un
sénateur
les républicains jean bizet puis je vous
fait réagir après et quand c'est un défi
qui font ce choix c'est un choix qui est
mûrement délibéré qui n'est pas fait au
doigt mouillé
donc il faut que ça il faut qu'ils
s'attendent à ce qu'ils ne seront pas
les bienvenues n'importe quel pays
ceci étant ces apatrides ne sont pas
pour autant je dirais voué à la vindicte
populaire parce que l'article 8 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme fait
en sorte que au niveau je dirais de la
vie privée au niveau d'un certain nombre
de deux modalités de leur vie ils ne
sont pas je dirais ils sont malgré tout
plus aisément protéger donc c'est qu'à
main malgré tout relativement doux par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait ce qu'ils
sont
voilà jean bizet donc il va plus loin
que la déchéance de nationalité pour les
binationaux lui donc on vous l'avez
entendu et veut carrément leur retirer
toutes nationalités donc c'est
effectivement comme ils le diront faire
les affaires des apatrides
moi je suis jamais partisan de
l'inflation de le viol l'inflation
législative
croyez-moi si en france toutes les lois
existantes étaient appliquées on n'en
serait pas là
donc l'urgence absolue c'est ce de se
doter moyens financiers et
organisationnels pour faire que les lois
qui sont votées elles soient réellement
appliquées
ça ira beaucoup mieux alors après est ce
qu'il faut juridiquement trouver de
nouveaux outils juridiques pourquoi pas
en discuter moi j'ai vu la proposition
qui a été fait depuis bien longtemps par
des députés
les républicains je pense notamment à
philippe meunier de déchoir de la
nationalité les binationaux condamné
pour des actes de terrorisme
j'ai encore en souvenir de la réponse
que nous faisait le gouvernement en
disant c'était scandaleux
je suis très heureux de voir aujourd'hui
gouvernement arrivait la bouche en coeur
en me disant qu'ils veulent le faire
mais voyez au fond même cette mesure là
c'est pas l'essentiel l'essentiel type
de la surenchère sécuritaire c'est le
risque un retrait mais rien de cinq mois
je ne suis pas dans ce registre là moi
ce que je souhaite c'est que la loi de
la république
elles soient pas facultative elle fois
appliquée et aujourd'hui vous avez
énormément de règles qui sont théoriques
mais qui en vrai ne sont pas appliquées
parce que l'état n'a pas les moyens de
se faire respecter
pour vous aider dans cette maison
d'arrêt vous voyez des détenus qui
fument du hachis dans les couloirs avec
des surveillants en face d'eux s'est
permis de fumer de la drogue dans un
bâtiment administratif avec un drapeau
français à l'entrée devant des agents
d'état non je ne le crois pas c'est une
façon s'il y en a mais à force de rogner
en permanence il a fait un instant au
delà de l'état alors je suis allée comme
une légende qu'est ce que vous avez à
dire là dessus bah écoutez il ya eu de
toute évidence et c'est même pas moi qui
le dit c'est malek boutih qui est
socialiste notamment et beaucoup
d'autres à gauche et eu parfois des élus
souvent de gauche qui ont distribué
beaucoup d'argent pour acheter la paire
pour parfois aussi des logiques
clientélistes va coûter tout ça c'est
terminé on ne travaille pas et des
associations finalement face à certains
il ya eu des lâchers d'eau radical c'est
ce que vous dites il ya eu des lâchetés
il ya eu du laisser aller il ya eu il ya
eu un éparpillement du jetair il ya eu
une efficacité de l'état qui n'a plus
été au rendez vous et a coûté l'exemple
le meilleur que je peux vous donner ce
que je vous donnais l'instant bien
quelqu'un qui est poursuivi par la
justice pour terrorisme cité confisquer
son passeport et qui la bouche en coeur
vue au commissariat du coin en disant on
me l'a volé on lui en fait un autre
voyez la nouvelle loi avant d'inventer
des nouvelles lois on va peut-être déjà
faire appliquer ce avec vos prérogatives
est ce que vous avez envie d'aller voir
ce qui se passe dans certaines
entreprises
oui enfin pour le coup les entreprises
privées on en a
la grande marée blick mais je vois dans
les maisons dans les entreprises
publiques portent tellement à la paix à
la sncf
l'urgence absolue valérie pécresse elle
a également proposé encore la semaine
dernière qui pourra comprendre à la ratp
et des gens qui soient fichés s pour des
problèmes de terrorisme parce que dans
la fiche s des gens qui sont sur des
fiches c'est ce qu'on a pas laissé
tomber un peu certains pans de la
laïcité française
on a vu une façon générale dans la
société française dsk pas une
coresponsabilité peut-être des
politiques de ces grandes entreprises
publiques
enfin la laïcité encore une fois le
principe en permettant d'ouvrir des
nations mais l'air dans un laisser aller
c'est des gens alors qu'il ya une loi
qui interdit le port de la burqa en
france être habillée comme ça dans la
rue et moi j'ai des collègues qui m'ont
expliqué que en gros il ya vu des
consignes qu'elle a été donné dans
beaucoup de départements de ne pas
interpeller des gens qui t'aiment le
voile intégral parce qu'il fait leur la
paix non pardon la règle de droit actuel
en france elle doit être appliquée alors
il n'y a pas le choix et c'est le jeu et
ceux qui ne veulent pas se soumettre aux
lois de la république ils ont rien à
faire sur l'espace public français
c'est ça la vérité donc vous êtes
d'accord avec emmanuel macron quand il
dit que finalement la responsabilité de
la france c'est d'avoir donné un terreau
favorable à la radicalisation
oui à la sagem pas non plus prendre le
sujet par là parce que souvent à gauche
autant emmanuel macron a des fois des
pauvres parfois des propositions
intéressantes notamment dans la sphère
économique moi je participais de ce
qu'ils considéraient que la loi macron
c'est une petite avancée est bon on n'a
pas eu l'occasion de voter pour ou
contre 1 parce que gouvernement n'avait
pas de majorité
autant ça c'est ce qu'on appelle la
culture de l'excusé moi je veux pas
laisser proliférer cette culture de
l'excusé qui pourrait justifier quoi que
ce soit la france est pas non plus un
pays qui n'est pas accueillants avec
tout le monde c'est un pays qui même
quand vous n'avez pas de revenus et vous
n'avez pas de travail vous donne des
allocations c'est un pays qui vous donne
la sécurité sociale même quand vous
n'avez pas de revenus et qui vous
garantit d'être soigné à l'hôpital quand
vous serez malade c'est un pays qui même
quand vos parents n'ont pas d'argent
vous offre la capacité de l école de
l'université et d'avoir une formation
qui vous permet de vous élever qu il n'a
pas beaucoup des pays au monde qu'il
faut autant pour tout le monde donc voir
aujourd'hui par emmanuel macron en
disant qu'on a créé un terreau
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est surtout
des lâchetés de la part des gouvernants
et un laisser aller général une non
maîtrise de nos finances publiques
de nos priorités qui a fait qu'on en
arrive là plutôt que notre modèle
d'accueil qui au contraire est très
gênant dernière gardien questions type
nostalgie en ce moment autour du service
national pour ou contre son retour
alors si on parle du service national
dans la partie militaire je suis contre
j'aimerais bien dans un monde absolu
mais la vérité c'est qu'on a supprimé en
1995 à peu près je crois de mémoire le
service nationale et qu'on n'a pas les
militaires pour l'encadrer et on n'a
plus les bases pour l'accueillir
donc ça me paraît assez démagogique
après concret un service un forçat de
vos amis vous êtes content que vous
entendre vous dispensez très
démagogiques
voilà je pense que c'est pas réaliste en
tout cas de faire cela par contre
d'avoir un service civique je vous
rappelle qu'il existe déjà qu'on les
généralistes plus oui vous savez voilà
moi droits et devoirs ça me paraît bien
s'il viendra plus aussi de voir des gens
merci ferrin nadège plus jack de la fp
arrive maintenant thierry solère avec
cette question pourquoi votre party les
républicains semblent à la peine à moins
de deux semaines donc maintenant des
élections régionales le paysage
politique et électoral bien sûr change
change forcément dans un état dans un
pays en état d'urgence écoutons ce qu'en
dit le politologue pascal perrineau
alors le république les républicains
l'associer à l'udps et au modem sont
pris un peu dans un étau ils ont à la
fois un front national qui sur leur
droite a retrouvé une certaine dynamique
et sur la gauche il avait un parti
socialiste qui était en train de se
déliter qui semble stopper ou freiner
son délitement donc l'espace qui de
progression qui était le leur et plus
compter qu'auparavant cela n'empêchera
pas certainement ses forces dans de
nombreuses régions d'emporter l'exécutif
mais le combat sera plus difficile
particulièrement où se goûte au vent
voilà donc un état des lieux politique
analyse recueilli quelques instants par
géraldine bach est bof bof enrichit le
sol air entendu monsieur perrineau donc
les républicains sont pris dans un étau
on sait ce qu'il nous dit vous avez vous
dit vous même tout à l'heure que le
président de la république et le
gouvernement
elle avait pioché à droite pour
présenter leurs mesures pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire vous
êtes vous on vous coupe l'herbe sous le
pied vous
c'est la même main vous êtes à la peine
c'était nous avantager la l'impression
de pas vieillir parce que à chaque
élection depuis trois ans en fin de
période préélectorale avant les
municipales avant les départementales et
maintenant avant les régionales
pour des raisons diverses celle là est
dans un contexte beaucoup plus triste
bien sûr on vient m'expliquer ça avant
les départementales
alors on vient me poser ces questions-là
avant les départementales en début
d'année on m'expliquait que c'était
terrible que françois hollande allait un
peu mieux que le front national
explosèrent était d'ailleurs on a les
noms mais c'est le député excusez moi et
là on a entendu monsieur perrineau qui
évoque un analyste politique et nous
expliquer que les républicains sont pris
dans un étau et c'est vrai on a fait
quand même le président de la république
et le premier ministre nous annoncer des
mesures que dont parle monsieur sarkozy
parle depuis un an je sais moi je vous
crois pas que les hommes politiques
soient dj quand il son pouvoir sur
l'horreur discours monsieur leurs actes
et on fera le bilan de la politique du
gouvernement et du président de la
république à la fin de son quinquennat
en matière d'emploi en matière
d'économie et en matière d'état régalien
et on verra si la situation était mieux
gérer à la fin du quinquennat françois
alors qu'au début et je ne crois pas
qu'aujourd'hui la france soit sur un
plan de l'emploi sur un an l'économie ou
sur un plan de la sécurité publique dans
un meilleur état qu'il ne l'était il a
pris entre deux feux quand même là de la
perspective des régionales
je vous parlais de questions dans la
perspective des régionales il assure
paca mais aussi dans la joie que vous
avez donc la gauche qui reprend un petit
peu de bol de poil de la bête on va dans
l'est dans les sondages et puis et puis
il ya le front national qui monte alors
bâtir de vous comment vous situez l'art
en matière de sondages je sais pas si on
est pris en étau mais si vous vous
intéressez aux fourrages et les liens je
vous avoue je les lis comme vous sung en
ile-de-france d'un autre bartolone au
même niveau que le front national à 22
et valérie on parle de la région paca le
candidat de socialistes qui représente
donc le gouvernement est crédité de 16%
d'intentions de vote donc voyez les taux
en tout cas qu'en dit le républicain le
quotidien le côté gauche de l'étau ne
prend pas beaucoup d'épaisseurs ces
temps ci à peu près dans toutes les
régions
après le front national est crédité de
l'attention doit très important dans de
nombreuses régions notamment on aurait
au sud oui parce que la politique du
gouvernement depuis trois ans c'est un
tract en plus grand pour le front
national
ces hausses d'impôts massives sur la
classe moyenne des gens qu'il ya une
2000 2500 euros par mois et on leur en
quoi comme service public derrière on
leur offre de la sécurité publique en
bas de la rue ou dans les transports
non on leur offre une entreprise à monde
économique compétitif où il y aura des
entreprises qui pourront être
compétitive et donc les embauches et non
plus alors les gens se désespère et de
la participation annoncée aux élections
est toujours basse et le vote pour les
extrêmes ne fait que monter la seule
chose qui nourrit le front national
c'est l'absence de résultats des
gouvernants voilà ce que je dis là on
parle quand même bien de la nouvelle
donne créée bien sûr par les attentats
et la politique le virage sécuritaire
bon va coûter si on part le jus de son
âge régionaux moi je vous dis par
exemple je suis tête de liste dans le
département des hauts-de-seine engagé
auprès de la mairie pécresse elle se
prépare à cette élection depuis
longtemps ils y apportent des réponses
précises pour qu'enfin on arrête de
dilapider de l'argent dans tous les sens
qu'on se concentre sur les missions
régaliennes de la région des transports
en commun rénové où on sentira en
sécurité des lycées rénové où nos gamins
se sont seront à la sécurité aux abords
et un développement économique pour
qu'on arrête de chasser les entreprises
à chaque fois qu'ils préfèrent aller
dans d'autres pays que chez nous voilà
les trois priorités bas côté qu'est ce
que je vois je vois que ça fait 17 ans
que les sociétés gèrent cette région
qu'ils ont eue le fait du clientélisme
comme jamais ils vont continuer à
construire des logements sociaux
allaient socialiste en ile de france
notamment je pense en seine saint denis
dans des villes où vous allez m'aider à
70% s'appelle fabriquer des ghettos eh
bien ils sont aujourd'hui récusé et vous
en arrivez à un niveau où le candidat
socialiste claude bartolone
il est crédité d'à peine du même score
dans notre sondage du sauvage qui vient
de sortir que le front national
oui la seule alternative posé là on doit
pas garder le même sondage parce que moi
j'avais plusieurs sondages ou est
crédité de 50% au deuxième tour comme
madame pécresse a cédé sondages à six
anciens depuis il les écarts se creusent
il vous avez un sondage où la proche
région
un sondage qui peut peut-être vous
plaire c'est bba pour le point qui vient
de sortir je crois aujourd'hui 17 points
en plus pour monsieur hollande les
français donc le créditent d'une bonne
gestion de la crise des événements et
aussi des bons points pour nicolas
sarkozy qui rassemble sa famille à
droite
est-ce que c'est aussi votre sentiment
mais c'est légitime et logique on avait
des amis ça malheureusement
au lendemain des attentats de charlie
que le président de la république et une
cote de confiance et le baudet pignon
qui est incroyablement riche
historiquement bas ce qui est arrivé au
niveau le plus bas qu'un président de la
vème république a pu avoir et un regard
de là il est arrivé au plus le moment ou
jamais connu oui voilà il partait de
très très bas alors voilà donc c'est
assez légitime mois les sondages je
viens commenté ça avec vous n'avez
spisak mais au fond c'est pas ça qui
m'importe est pardon je termine là
dessus ce qu'ils voudront les gens me
semble-t-il ans aux élections régionales
c'est d'avoir à la tête de la région des
gens qui arrêtent de dilapider l'argent
on sait pas où ça va et qui leur rendent
qui leur rendent dans des transports
dans des lycées et de développement
économiques c'est-à-dire les trois
grandes compétences de la région de
qualité et ça nous on a des candidats de
bon niveau et valérie pécresse notamment
en ile-de-france et très préparés à cela
au lendemain des régionales en trois
dans une nouvelle séquence la
présidentielle de 2017 me semble-t-il
les français chercheront à la tête de
l'état celui ou celle qui incarnera des
solutions concrètes crédible pour que
l'économie aille mieux et surtout que la
sécurité publique soit assurée pas dans
des grands discours mais dans les actes
alors avant de parler de 17 on va parler
de ce qui se passe maintenant on a bien
vu la toile à l'impression en vous
écoutant depuis tout à l'heure depuis
début d'émission que comme les
républicains sont très embêtés entre le
devoir d'unité nationale et puis votre
rôle d'opposant vous avez dit à
plusieurs reprises ce qui était que
votre rôle d'opposant alors est-ce que
vous pensez que les républicains
notamment le président des républicains
à monsieur nicolas sarkozy vous avez
bien placé le curseur entre ces deux
pôles et tout le monde sait que c'est
pas évident pour vous comment comment
vous le ressentez bon c'est très
difficile d'en au lendemain d'attentats
le rôle d'opposant ce n'est pas quelque
chose que les gens attendent aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ils attendent quoi il attend
qu'on continue d'arrêter à ceux qui ont
commis ces attentats terroristes étaient
toujours pas le cas il reste des gens on
les poursuit jusqu'en belgique
donc il ya une peur et c'est l'exécutif
le gouvernement qui est à la manoeuvre
sur ce sujet après peut-être te dire que
on va arrêter de parler des sondages
mais peut-être que l'opinion une partie
de l'opinion publique française vous
reproche un ton trop virulente
devenir parent donc la semaine dernière
à l'assemblée nationale la séance a été
très houleuse et on a beaucoup dit on a
beaucoup entendu on a beaucoup lu que
c'était de la faute des députés
républicains
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont abusé de députés
républicains n'ont pas été pris une fois
à crier dominici que je n'ai pas un mode
de fonctionnement avaler à l'assemblée
nationale je vous le dire
une quinzaine de députés à gauche et une
quinzaine de députés à droite qui ont
comme mode d'expression le hurlement
régulièrement et pas que dans ces
moments là le problème c'est que vous
comptez dans ces moments là ce n'est
plus étonnant c'est pitoyable et on a
été dans boel dire en direct
bon écoute et voilà depuis le calme est
revenu et moi ce que j'attends de ma
famille politique et elle le fait vous
savez le matin même on avait eu nicolas
sarkozy qui était venue à la réunion de
groupe
devant les parlementaires il a lu un
discours très précis très apaisé il nous
avait dit au départ en fin
d'intervention que concernant les
régionales ça c'est pas le sujet
personne sait rien on verra bien que les
français nous regarder tous et que les
français dans ces moments là et regardez
les hommes politiques pour essayer de
savoir qui était crédible pour apporter
des réponses concrètes discours apaisé
de monsieur sarkozy pendant la réunion
robert qu'est ce qui s'est passé l'après
midi il s'est passé que je vous dis une
dizaine de personnes qui à gauche comme
à droite a inscrit beaucoup y en a sans
excuser seul à s'en excuser leur
comportement qui qui était en colère qui
était en colère quand vous êtes un
député qui a surtout en colère ils le
sont en permanence qui hic est en colère
qui quand vous êtes présenté ce qui
n'est pas mon cas qui a déposé une
proposition de loi à nos nombreuses
reprises pour lutter efficacement contre
le terrorisme participer en tout cas et
qu'on vous moque qu'on vous dit c'est la
surenchère qu'on vous dit que vous
courrez derrière le front national et
que vous voyez le chef de l'état le
premier ministre arrivé la bouche en
coeur au lendemain de 130 morts en
reprenant exactement mot pour mot aux
propositions ya de la colère tiens à ce
propos de terrorisme le l'ancien
policier chef de la police monsieur
squarcini a fait une île à une interview
à valeurs actuelles ces seules où il dit
qu' il y a deux ans il était approché
par les syriens qui ont dit voilà on est
prêt à vous donner des listes de
terroristes de français
qu'ils viennent en syrie mais évidemment
en échange il faut un petit peu de
coopération avec nous et paraît-il que
le gouvernement le nôtre aurait refusé
est ce que vous êtes au courant de cette
histoire j'ai bien sûr lui c'est
l'information est d'ailleurs j'attends
des explications très claires parce
qu'il ya deux solutions soit bernard
qu'on se croit cynique était le patron
du renseignement intérieur français
n'importe qui à l'époque des faits dit
vrai ça veut dire que les autorités
syriennes et les services de
renseignements syriens au proposé à la
france une liste de france est engagée
dans des activités terroristes et on
l'aurait refusée si c'est ça c'est d'une
extrême gravité
ou bien c'est faux il ya des poursuites
qui doivent être engagés l'endroit de
monsieur squarcini parce qu'on atteindra
dire des choses de cette nature
donc moi j'attends du gouvernement et de
manuel valls qui nous disent exactement
la vérité qu'il en tire toutes les
conséquences
bon alors on va parler maintenant des
régionales on en a parlé on a vu qu'ils
avaient une incidence de ces événements
sur les régionales mais vous espérez
quand même avoir beaucoup de régions le
goûter aux dames auront toutes les
régions sont gouvernés par la gauche
et qu'est ce que je constate je constate
qu'il ya un élan quand même énormément
de région aujourd'hui et je constate
aussi parce que j'oublie les sondages
que le front national notamment au nord
et au sud de la france est très élevé je
pense que la seule alternative dans le
coup je populaire que vous je ne sais
pas si ça veut dire que ça je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens exaspérés et
que le front national c'est bien ramener
à lui les électeurs exaspérés
maintenant quand les électeurs attendent
des réponses très concrètes et des
changements sur un plan économique et
sur un plan de la sécurité je ne suis
pas certain que ce soit la meilleure
solution je pense que la seule
alternative possible
c'est les républicains et que ça
marchera à une seule condition c'est que
nous nous proposions des solutions
crédibles pas des facilités et c'est ce
que nous faisons nombreuses régions et
moi je suis persuadé valérie pécresse
ras el juli de frange persuadée bruno
retailleau reprendra à la gauche la
région des pays de la loire
je suis persuadé carrément rhin
reprendra la région normandie nous
sommes sûrs que vous avez des doutes
tout le monde le voit bien c'est dans la
région nord pas de calais picardie et
dans la région paca que la situation est
bien sûr très tendue mais je pense que
sinon les républicains ont large
victoire à l'occasion de ces élections
régionales 2
non après les régionales qu'est ce qui
va se passer les primaires des clés
original voix est terminée vous avez
tous vous mettre sur la primaire comment
est-ce que ça se passe chez vous côté ça
se passe bien on s'est engagé dans cette
affaire qui est nouvelle pour nous elle
a primé à pourquoi parce que tout le
monde comprend bien que vous pensez à
avoir des dents après ce sacre un joujou
mois des dents que deux candidats sur
l'organisation par exemple les murs
haute-vallée juste mon raisonnement mais
je rappelle que vous êtes chargé de
l'organisation tête prix les prix ou en
êtes-vous
alors on en n'est qu'un d'abord pourquoi
on a fait ça parce qu'on ne peut pas
avoir deux candidats de la droite et du
centre candidats pour des temps de la
présidentielle tout le monde le comprend
bien
et donc c'est le seul moyen bien sûr
c'est nouveau pour nous bien sûr c'est
tiré plein de questionnements mais le
parti au travail oui avant de venir à
cette émission j'étais encore avec
l'ensemble des membres du comité
d'organisation
on se réunit tous les soirs et des
nouvelles toutes fraîches et en agence
écoutez la haute autorité est maintenant
complétée elle et elle s'est engagée sur
un plan financier le parti politique et
république a fait un gros travail de
restructuration et a dans son budget
2000 16 5 millions d'euros pour
organiser cette primaire donc le
financement de la primaire est bouclé et
les notes en train de finir de boucler
la lamination pas très sympathique sur
ce financement de la primaire à savoir
que chez pardon les juppéiste on
s'énerve beaucoup parce que euh si j'ai
bien compris veulent une structure
externe au parti pour le financement et
puis le sarkozysme ne veulent pas vous
pouvez nous expliquer un petit peu ce
qui se passe ça tire vraiment j'ai
vraiment des gros tiraillements chez ou
est ce que c'est vrai ou est ce qu'on
nous raconte des bêtises je pense que ça
peut arriver qu'on vous raconter des
fils parce que sincèrement ça se passe
bien
ça va aussi parce qu'on s'entend bien
les uns les autres moi je m'entends très
bien avec brice hortefeux avec edouard
philippe qui travailleraient un juppé et
on se parle en franchise
aujourd'hui on s'est engagé dans cette
affaire on a listé les endroits où il y
aura des bureaux de vote
on a les structures juridiques précis de
droits de vote soit organisé pour les
français de l'étranger ça se passera par
un vote par internet et par le
financement moi je veux saluer le
travail de daniel fasquelle qui le
trésor des républicains puisque dans le
budget 2016 du parti il ya 5 millions
qui ont été votés il ya huit jours au
conseil à dix quinze jours maintenant au
conseil national des républicains dans
le livre extrêmement être externalisées
pour la haute autorité dans tout le
monde est d'accord sur le sujet est ce
que vous avez réussi à rassurer les
sarkozystes qui ai trouvé que le nombre
de bureaux de vote et 10000 était
excessif et 1
gérable non franchement je dis ça aussi
mais je n'ai pas entendu ça chez les
déclarations publiques il ya demain il
ya dans le sud de la france et dans
l'est
quelques maires présidents de
départements qui considèrent qu'il ya
trop de bureaux de vote dans l'ouest est
passé dans l'est à melwood tout ça c'est
des détails pardon c'est presque de
parler tout ça aujourd'hui
au fond on est engagé dans cette logique
de primaire tout le monde voit bien
qu'on pourra pas faire autre chose que
les affaires et vraiment on y va et on
organisera dans un an pile 20 novembre
2016 une lâche primaire ce qui permettra
à toute personne qui se revendiquent des
valeurs de la droite et du centre de
venir voter pas uniquement des
adhérentes partis politiques dernière
question
voilà on va vous soutenez toujours
monsieur bruno le maire écoutez c'est
pour être franc moi je suis engagé
auprès de bruno ça se passe très bien et
on est dans un comité d'organisation ou
et leurs films soutient alain juppé ou
d'occasion on verra bien qui sera
candidat la fin et surtout on soutiendra
tous le vainqueur de la primaire
on suivra tout cela merci beaucoup
siaved merci tirées ces dernières heures
est avec nous ce soir bonsoir à tous et
à bientôt